the bacteria in wheels lungs are deeply
colonized antibiotic penetration into
the lung tissue takes time and
superflous Marlon is no different if
it's not being effective enough I'm
sorry if I'm interfering with your phone
by trying to save your life
where's mother of the year I know I knew
this wasn't going to work
you arguing with her is not going to
make things any better you're the one
who's making things worse okay fine then
let's just stop doing the treatment it's
stop spending all this money let's just
stop trying but then what
I'm sorry I don't live in a fairy tale
I live in the real world where people
solve their problems how I am
no you're not a problem you're my son
and just be my mom do you even know who
I am what kind of person I am you know
there's a girl I like do you know what
music I enjoy who my favorite artist is
I spend all of my time in this place
you're out there we have nothing in
common all you see is my [ __ ] disease
if you want a problem to fix fix the way
that you look at me